[Music]
China is offering a new vision of the
internet one which combines sweeping
content curbs with uncompromising data
controls the idea is called cyber
sovereignty and it's already spreading
around the world this is your bloomberg
quick take on the new cyber cold war
welcome it's the new millennium and a
simpler time for the internet Western
tech pioneers proclaim it's a borderless
force for transparency and individual
freedom but fast forward to now and
that's being challenged like never
before a massive cyber attack affecting
nearly 50 million Facebook users and it
was my mistake and I'm sorry even if
you're not doing anything wrong you're
being watched you want to win a war you
need weapons for that and we could we
could build them that's been a global
backlash against Facebook Google wants
app this backlash coin Sciences rise of
the Chinese model today you have
governments from Russia to Southeast
Asia saying hey Mon we get to control
content on the Internet
and at the same time that is not an
impediment to stunning economic growth
it's an ideological coup and a rejection
of the American Internet model which
promised to spur innovation and freedom
now China is offering a different vision
both internet control and tech
innovation and it has fans today that
would be a growing number of people who
would argue that controlling the flow of
information across the Internet does not
actually impede innovation the crux of
the Chinese internet model is based
around the nation-state setting their
own rules for your own citizens that
can't be circumvented by the internet so
very simply they want to control what
sort of content is hosted on the
Internet that's available to Chinese
users and and they want absolute control
over that content so if they decide for
instance that they don't want any
references to the gentleman mess
of 1989 then they will scrub that out of
every every website and every app within
the countries that Chinese consumers can
see and this controlled moderated
version of the Internet is spreading
especially across Southeast Asia Viet
Nam's controversial version of the
Chinese internet model went into effect
in 2019 it demands the data of
Vietnamese users is kept in the country
Indonesia Southeast Asia's largest
economy already requires data to be
stored locally the Philippines has
stepped up what critics call a media
crackdown and one of the latest to buy
into the rationale is Thailand which
passed a cybersecurity bill modeled on
China's Southeast Asia is the testing
ground for Chinese ambitions the region
is home to more than half a billion
people whose internet economy is
expected to triple to 240 billion
dollars by 2025 I think a lot of Chinese
companies and potentially Beijing itself
see Southeast Asia as the first step in
expanding their influence globally but
that's where the digital cold wall kind
of differs from the Cold War were
familiar with in this case I think
countries are adopting the Chinese style
model without necessarily subscribing to
Beijing style of government and/or
Beijing's agenda China's version of the
Internet is appealing to other nations
who want to control what their
populations see and hear but it doesn't
mean China's calling the shots instead
it could create an unprecedented
bifurcation of the Internet effectively
ending our notion of a truly worldwide
web
meaning what information you can easily
access would depend on where you are and
what that government decides you should
know
you